- [Instructor] Let's see if
we can draw the Lewis diagram
for a nitrate anion.
So a nitrate anion has one
nitrogen and three oxygens,
and it has a negative charge.
I'll do that in another color.
It has a negative charge.
So pause this video and
see if you can draw that,
the Lewis structure for a nitrate anion.
All right, well we've
done this many times.
The first step is to just account
for the valence electrons.
Nitrogen has one, two, three,
four, five valence electrons
in its outer shell, and
in that second shell,
if it's a neutral, free nitrogen atom.
So we have five valence electrons there.
Oxygen has one, two, three, four, five,
six valence electrons.
But if you have three oxygens,
you're going to have six times three.
And so if you just add
up the valence electrons,
if these were free, neutral atoms,
you would get five plus 18,
which is 23 valence electrons.
Now the next thing we have to keep
in mind is this is an anion.
This has a negative one
charge right over here.
So it's going to have
one more extra electron,
one more extra valence
electron than you would expect
if these were just free
atoms that were neutral.
So let's add one valance electron here.
So that gets us to 24 valence electrons.
And then the next step is let's try
to actually draw this structure.
And the way we do it is we try
to pick the least electronegative atom
that is not hydrogen
to be the central atom.
And in this case it is nitrogen.
It's to the left of oxygen
in that second period.
So let's put nitrogen in the center,
right over there.
And around it let's put three oxygens.
So one, two, three oxygens.
Let's put a single bond between them.
And so so far we, and let me do that
in another color, so we
can account for it better.
So I'll do them in purple.
So so far we have accounted for two, four,
six valence electrons.
So minus six valence electrons gets us
to 18 valence electrons.
The next step is we would try to allocate
as many of these as possible
to our terminal atoms,
the oxygens over here.
Try to get them to a full octet.
So let's do that.
This, each of these oxygens,
they're already participating in one
of these covalent bonds,
so they already have two
valence electrons hanging out.
So let's see if we can
give them each another six,
to get to eight.
So two, four, six.
Two, four, six.
And then two, four, and six.
And so just like that
we have allocated 18 valence electrons,
six, 12, 18.
So minus 18 valence electrons.
And we are now left with no
further valence electrons
to allocate.
But let's see how our atoms are doing.
We know the oxygens have a full octet,
but the nitrogen only has two, four,
six valance electrons hanging around.
It would be great if there
was a Lewis structure
where we could have
eight valence electrons
for that nitrogen.
Well one way to do that is to take one
of these lone pairs
from one of the oxygens
and turn that into another covalent bond.
So let's do that.
So let me just erase this
pair right over here,
and I'm just going to turn that
into another covalent bond.
And this is looking pretty good.
We have eight valence
electrons around each
of the oxygens.
And now we have eight for the nitrogen,
two, four, six, eight.
And we have to remind ourselves
that this is an anion.
It has a negative one charge.
So to finish the Lewis diagram
we would just put that
negative charge there.
And this is all well and good,
but if this was the only
way that nitrate existed
when we observed nitrate
anions in the world,
we would expect to see one shorter bond
and two longer bonds,
and we would expect one
of the bonds to have a different energy
than the other two.
But in the real world we don't see that.
We see that all of the bonds
actually have the same length,
and they actually have the same energy.
And so an interesting
question is why is that?
And one thing that you
might appreciate is,
when I took that lone pair
to create this covalent bond,
I could have done it with that top oxygen.
I could have done it with
this bottom-left oxygen.
Or I could have done it with
that bottom-right oxygen.
And so there's actually
three valid Lewis structures
that we could have had.
Not only could we have
had this Lewis structure,
we could have had this one,
and I'll draw it all in
yellow to save us some time,
where you have this nitrogen.
It has a single bond with that top oxygen.
And so that top oxygen
still has six electrons
in lone pairs.
And maybe it forms a double bond
with the bottom-left oxygen.
So this bottom-left oxygen
only has two lone pairs.
One of them would have gone
to form the double bond.
And then this oxygen would look the same.
So what I am drawing here is
another valid Lewis structure.
Or the double bond might have formed
with this bottom-right oxygen,
so let me draw that.
So another valid Lewis
structure could look like this.
So nitrogen bonded to that
oxygen has three lone pairs.
This oxygen also has three lone pairs.
And now this one has the double bond
and only has two lone pairs.
And whenever we see a situation
where we have three
valid Lewis structures,
we call this resonance.
Resonance.
And we'll put an arrow,
these two-way arrows
between these structures.
And when you hear the word resonance,
it sometimes conjures up this image
that you're bouncing
back, you're resonating
between these structures.
But that's actually not right.
What the right way to think about it is,
these different ways of
visualizing the nitrate,
these contribute to a resonance hybrid,
which is really the true way
that the nitrate exists.
And so, if we wanted to
draw a resonance hybrid,
it would look like this.
You have the nitrogen in the center.
You have your oxygens, one, two, three.
I can draw our first
covalent bond like that.
And then you would show the bond
between nitrogen and each
of these oxygens are a
hybrid between someplace
between a single bond and a double bond.
And so instead of just one of
them having the double bond
and the other two having single bonds,
they're all somewhere in between.
So maybe you draw a dotted line,
something like that, to
show what the reality is,
is that you actually have three bonds
that are someplace in between a single
and a double bond, because the electrons
in this molecule are
delocalized throughout.
And of course you wanna make sure,
you always wanna make
sure that people recognize
that this is a anion.
So this is the idea of resonance.
You have multiple valid Lewis structures.
They all contribute to a resonance hybrid,
which is actually what we observe.
We're not just bouncing between
these different structures.
The actual observation will
be a hybrid of the three.
Now what we just drew here,
these three are all equivalent.
But in certain cases, we'll see this
in future videos, you don't
have equivalent structures,
and some of them might contribute more
to the resonance hybrid than others.
But we'll see that in future videos.